Wow.
Well go to your mom's house,
Christina.
All right,
here we are.
Happy to be back another week.
We got some uh,
gigs coming up. Um, I just
added a show in Phoenix,
standup live fart.
Nick's Arizona part of it.
I added a show Thursday, December 7th.
Here's what's going on that week. Um,
so far, December 8th, the
early show is sold out.
The late show has about a hundred
tickets left and Saturday.
Both shows are sold out. So we added
one Thursday, December 7th and Phoenix.
After that, it's, um, after
her what he going to do? The,
uh,
Performing Arts Center in Maui December
14th and the Hawaii Theater and Honolulu
on a Saturday,
December 16th.
Get tickets at Thomson [inaudible]
dot com slash tour and a yeah.
Scoop him up before they're
gone. Gene, what about you?
I'm talking about 2018 now. January
12th. I'm at the Pasadena Ice House.
That'd be wary.
Second and third and sharp lake.
Teddy's Utah at wiseguys comedy club.
February 23rd,
the Colusa Casino. And then, uh,
March 30th and 31st in Portland,
Oregon at helium comedy club.
So come check me out their tickets
at Christina p online. Nice.
And our great gifts
today.
You may know him from going
to church regularly and uh,
he's gracing us with first time in
years that he's been back on our show.
It is the great Jose Joey Coco Diaz.
Wow. Saplings. Good morning. And
uh, just to get it out of the way,
let people know you're going to be in
Sacramento. Sacramento, the seventh,
eighth and ninth. Oh Great.
I'm in the same boat as you.
Saturday soul down
Friday fro show sold out.
So we got two shows left.
That's it. They're going to
be gone. What venue is this?
You're doing the best.
We have a walker that third,
fourth and fifth. Oh, with all wheeler.
He's doing shows with wheeler. Oh,
that's fun. Yeah, we had him on a,
yeah, he's a great guy. He's great.
No vote data observatory in San
Diego and Observatory in Santa Ana.
Let's see how comedy country.
Yeah.
Well there you go. Um,
you know what it is.
I don't fuck with like, all right.
Shall we do, I don't fuck with who?
Lincolnton. Oh, Lincoln. Yeah.
Do you still get to still get invitations?
One 8,000 quest.
A weak link to say much
on Facebook. Yeah. Okay.
Black to now I've got another
page and how to work with,
so do you have a profile on linkedin?
I think somebody actually just
broke down and made one for me.
Uh, let's get this show started.
We're going to open the show and uh,
we'll get into a whole bunch
of stuff with Joey Diaz.
I'm not talking to you. Why did
you abandon this kid? What are you,
do you want me to have a home?
You want me to find it at home?
You're not taking care of it. Don't
you look at me like, what the fuck?
I'm a drag. Take that Goddamn cat
pajamas. I'll get as doesn't do it.
Don't bring it
to your mom's house.
You got the,
uh,
the cat lady here because
Joey is a cat man.
You know that he loves cats. I do know
that. How many do you have? Seven.
Seven. He's like, he's a cat whisperer.
Like he really connects with cats. Yeah.
I love my babies. Yeah. And this
lady right here loves cats too.
She's mad at this neighbor because she's
saying that the neighbor is not taking
care of the cat, you know? Yeah.
I'm sorry.
The middle with you.
You're on my property bitching over
things that are not of your concern.
I get a fin because when
she comes by your house,
she obviously comes by your
house and pisses you off.
And I asked if that was the issue and it
is he issue because you say that to me.
Your goddamn kid.
It's you.
You're the one that said
people should be responsible
for your dog.
She's really upset. Yeah. She's saying
that he's not taking care of this cat.
This is how my mother used to yell at
people like over really mundane shit.
She be like, you'll fuck mother fuck
ass. You fucking bitch the fucking,
she hated cats. She would just come.
I'm other people like that all the time.
And she hated cats. There was one cat,
uh, we live in an apartment complex.
It used to piss on our,
our doormat.
And she waited for the cat
to come and she kicked it.
She would fucking open our door and she
kicked it down the stairs. Jesus. No,
it never came back, I guess. But then
she'd find the owner and be like, Yo,
mother Fucker, you're fucking cat
pcs or low one of my fucking door.
You fucking Cock sucker Gaga.
Gaga.
Oh my God. No plane. No gain.
No plane.
No gain.
Yeah. Yeah. Well, what'd you
do, Joey? Does your cat wander
and other people's yards?
No, they'll let them out of the
house. Oh, they're strictly house.
I can't sleep at night knowing
my little Fox or outside. Yeah.
Getting attacked by a rack
cooling or something like that.
Was it a,
was it a like a thing for
your wife to get used to like,
or was she already in the cats too?
In other words, now we want to were
together. She had a kitten. That was it.
That was when I first started
dating and she had a kid.
And did you have a cat already?
Thick. Oh, okay. Like cats.
I don't even know. Really?
Yeah. I didn't know have any idea. And
then when, where we lived Hollywood,
there was a lot of cats and
they would die in the backyard.
So I would wake up in the morning,
it'd be three dead kittens.
So we started saving them and call them
different organizations and they'd pick
them up and feed them. Oh, I didn't
know how you got into it. Yeah,
the one by one I started bringing
them upstairs and they became middle.
Somebody would go, I'm moving in a
month I want, because it was Siamese.
There was gorgeous,
and they go on removing save me one.
Then they call me back and go, well,
my roommate has an elephant, so no,
I can't have a cat. So I get stuck
at the fucking cat. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
So I let stuck with
[inaudible] loving them.
At one time I found homes for
four of them, five of them.
How would you find homes?
Different people, different
girls, guys, acting classes,
whatever.
And then I moved to the valley with six
and I moved to the valley and there was
one that started hanging around the
house just hanging out with me at night.
I would get home from the store and
whistle and it would fucking come to me.
If I would walk down the corner,
it would follow me. Yeah,
and the owner came through when,
then she goes, I can't control her,
but obviously you can.
She pays attention to you and she got
attacked by a possum and she couldn't
staff side no more. So just
said, just take her. Wow.
She's one of my best cat.
It's so funny to me like,
and I don't know why it's like this.
Maybe it's like this to other people.
Cats to me or just,
it's not that I have any issue with them.
They're like a foreign language to me.
You know what I mean? Like I,
I don't know how to gauge cats.
I don't know what to expect from
because I never grew up with them.
I've never spent time with cats, so like
to me like a dog feels familiar. Yeah.
I kind of, I kind of know what to expect
from a dog. I know how to approach a dog.
I know,
you know,
I know dog behavior pretty much like
having grown up with dogs with cats,
I'm always like,
I don't know what what I was supposed
to do because it's all their rules.
I feel like. Yeah, they got to tell you
it's that they tell you what's up, right.
You tell a dog what's up and cat world,
they have to choose you.
Like what joy was saying like
that cat shows Joey. Yeah.
And respect him and then they do,
they pick a person.
What's interesting is that
it came to him later in life.
Like I would have thought that he
was like growing up with cats. No,
but you just figured cats out
like way later a friend. Yeah.
Growing up had a cat. Yeah. That
was a fucking guy. He was a warrior.
He was missing and here he
was missing half his foot.
His name was frisky. And I still remember
one particular morning when, you know,
when you get fucked up at your friend's
house and you wake up the next day and
you were on the floor.
Yeah.
Like I woke up and the window was open
and we were freezing and he was in the
window watching a bird in the tree.
Like making that fucking noise. Yeah.
I never heard that noise.
I hadn't ever seen it where
the cat sees an animal vets,
he's about to attack.
He'll make weird,
hey, hell yeah. Don't
make little weird noises.
Yeah.
And an hour later we got the mother made
us all breakfast and gave us a lecture
on why not to drink and you know,
look what the would look,
what's going to happen with you guys and
if forget Christina opening the door.
That bird was in shambles.
Like he brought it to us as a gift.
Then the mother explained, she's like,
I don't know what he's going to bring.
He shows up with fucking dead cats,
birds, squirrels. Killer man. I liked him.
Yeah,
he wasn't mine.
But I liked him and that was
my only experience with cats.
And then 30 years later you go
to people's homes to have a cat.
The cat jumps on you, they show
you affection, so they call you,
you get scared and you push
them off. Yeah, that's,
that's part of the fear
that I had. Yeah. Yeah.
Then it's weird once you save the cat,
they remember that they, they,
they, they remember everything.
I used to have a friend that goes,
I'll fuck with cats because they're
going to go to bed and they write it down
and they get you later. They
write it down. It's really weird.
I was going through a weird time in my
life and these cats would come into the
house at the time. We both
needed each other like it
was the weirdest thing. Yeah.
And when I come home at night and
doing comedy, they're scattered.
But once I go to the office and I make
my notes about my sat and what I got to
do the next day,
once I go into the living room and unwind,
they come out one by one and I got to
give them all attention and talk to them
and ask them what's going
on with Dan World and seven,
some of them don't come out. Two of them.
You, you'll never see the two girls. Yeah.
Lou Levy.
Evie lives by the door.
So I touched her and touch her in the way
in and out. That's my good luck charm.
She lives by the door.
She watches that fucking door.
I wonder if I would just go
into fits of sneezing and like,
and weeping if I walked into your place
because I have like, no, I brushed him.
I really keep the gander, the
dander down. Yeah. You know,
I've been around cats where, um, I slept
at a place, uh, in a friend's place.
I crashed with her for like six weeks,
uh,
just out of college and he had two little
cats and like my eyes would just start
to, you know, water and
I would just, I dunno,
I mean I never,
like I said,
that was my first exposure and then they
would chase each other in the morning
and they would like run over
my face as they're chasing.
So I'd have like cat
scratches on my forehead.
Like right now you guys
have dogs and a child,
you have to have the things that
bring you the most love. You know,
you just went to Toledo,
Ohio,
it fucking snowed Saturday,
you were expected to sell out,
but then you get to the airport and the
flight was delayed and then Thompson
grow. His flight is delayed and he
was supposed to go to Burke crisis.
Birthday party. Yeah. You get home
and your, and your luggage is lost.
And now the Uber drive race showing
up and you walk in your door and,
and you gotta take a shit and
you have do all these things.
But that dog comes up to you that first
you really want to kick that dog. Yeah.
At first you want to go, you know what?
Do me a favor, get the fuck away from me.
What? He does not understand. No, he just
wants to give you this election. Yeah.
I tell you something when you
bend over and just pat them. Yeah.
All of those problems you had that
morning and you're a human being. Yeah.
They just disappear. That's
true. That's absolutely true.
Just go away for five minutes and you
pick them up and you pat them and they
look at you and the five minutes.
Yeah, Tom's delayed. Right.
We're not going to make birthday party,
but it all seems a lot better.
It's 100% true. It really even when
your child, sometimes you come home,
you didn't get the audition,
they gave it to somebody else and
you pick up your kid and you go,
who gives a fuck?
Of course I don't give a fuck of
Ralph's blows up right now. Yeah.
I don't give a fuck. I got my kid.
Yeah. It's 60 minutes is on. I know.
Yeah.
As well. We're both, we're both, uh,
three of us are all prefer to be home.
I think the three of us are like just get,
get home yet our animals and
play with our kids and watch TV.
My happiest time in life,
my happiest moment of the day is when we
put the baby down. He's had a great day.
He's in his crib.
He just fell asleep.
Tom and I are laying in bed with the
two dogs and we're watching some stupid
show. Yeah. That's my, that's
why I live. Yeah. Everything
else is like, man, I know.
It's almost like you live the
day to get to that model. No,
it's really like you can,
I feel like the,
I can feel that clock counting down to
that moment later in the day when it's 30
minutes away. I'm like, oh,
we're going to be in bed doing our
thing with dogs watching TV pretty soon.
Pretty excited. We have
three. We have to it too.
Yeah. It's funny how, uh, you know,
we all became as comics and when
you become a comic, you know,
like right now me and Tom lost a lot
of weight because when you become a
comedian you put all your focus
into becoming a comedian. Yeah.
I'll figure it onion rings at the bar
and you'll eat. Yeah. On your rings,
you go back to the hotel
room. Doritos. Yeah.
It's so weird how we've
evolved as Comedians,
but at the same time now you're like
family, like led Zeppelin was great,
awesome legs up with the fifth Albert,
he started spitting out kids. Yeah,
the toys got delayed. Yeah. And you know,
cause you said going, wait a second,
I got to go on the road and do what?
I'd much rather just play on the fucking
floor with this child. Of course.
Whatever the fuck it is.
It's a,
yeah, no man, I know it's a being home is,
it's like it's the goal now.
Like you just try to design your life
to be at home as much as you can because
the first fucking 10 years
you live on the road.
Yeah. It's horrible. I mean,
my goal is to just not,
first of all, to not wear decent pants.
Like I always want to be in sweatpants,
number one.
Like that's the whole dream.
And then to be home I like
to do as little as possible.
That's the whole goal for me. Like I want
to retire at 50 have a fucking dog. Oh,
he's had a really big respect
for you as a woman. Comics.
I didn't want to say woman comic is a
comic because when you were around me,
I didn't feel like I had to act
really differently, you know? Yeah.
So I was very concerned about you
when you had your child, you know,
I'm so glad you're bringing this up.
I was very concerned about
you and your career affect.
Tom And I had a conversation
on a plane that I said to him,
how's Christine handling this?
Because I have friends like Joe Rogan
that they'd give a fuck about the Mars and
if the world is flat and look at this
animal and I could give a fuck about that.
I love,
I love the mind and love psychology
and I love to see the change of people.
Nobody,
nobody,
nobody changed more than my redneck.
You know,
my wife present work. My wife was one of
those people. That job was eight to five.
That's on paper and her world,
it's seven to when the job gets done.
You know, my wife is one of those people
that, you know, you took a job. Yeah,
you took it for $10 an hour. You got to do
the work. Yeah, you don't like it. Quit.
But why are you making a commitment?
There are Americans that people that my
wife had no days off and 10 years as an
accountant, she never took a sick
day. Never took a personal day.
She took three hours one time when I
was doing coke because I got like an 18
grand trek and she wanted to make sure
the check made it to the bank and not
like coke dealers house.
It was one of the biggest checks I've
ever got ever for residual. She left.
You took a train,
you know when my wife had
the baby and my wife said,
I'll be there in five minutes to help
you cash that check and they'll put it in
the proper. That was the only
time in 10 years at the op,
at the Walt, the center,
she had the child,
she had all this sick time.
She had all this paternity time.
It was like five months and I could see
her going through paperwork at night,
Gung Ho about it,
and then she got to go back to
work and I tried to help her.
I tried to, you know, what do
I cook? Hamburger help. Yeah,
I know how to make hamburger helper,
but Joe, y'all are cocoa chicken.
All the cocoa chicken cutlets with lemon
and pepper and the jelly specialties.
I know three recipes.
I think everybody only knows three.
When I saw my wife go
from 40 hours a week,
this gun loving toadying American
who believes in a dollar a day,
you know a day's work for a day's pay.
I saw cut her hours to 30 then 20
then 20 and then she came home one day.
She goes,
I'm just going to become a
consultant. And I go, no, you're not.
You're just not gonna work your 45 this
is never ever going to happen again
unless some miracle,
God gives me another squirt
of good nut juice you are in.
We were lucky we got this little squeezing
that juice out with all the marijuana.
I smoked and I saw her transformation.
So I was always real interested
in Christine's transformation.
I was very interested in
what she got pregnant and how
she was gonna react to it.
And you know,
do you have the child and I,
so now she doesn't work right wife.
I tell him what's to use. Yeah, what it,
she came home two weeks ago with some
story about a I AFI and a firewall for the
six figures and she'll put mercy
at the Catholic school over there.
And as we were driving one day
go take a look at the one on one.
Yeah.
Is that what you want at your app?
Is that what you wanted your
rights wrapped up at five
you got to pick up mercy
and then drive her home and then,
oh, guess who's cooking at six?
Chef Diaz,
chef boy dick.
Cause I know how to make steak comes
and or Ida French fries with American
cheese on white bread to stake comes shit.
Yeah,
we all did white trash.
Your transformation was,
and it's so weird how he's so funny.
I love women that are Gung Ho and
one day the uterus costs. Yeah,
once you lose, because that's it. That's
the biggest call a woman could get.
Everything goes out the window,
everything.
It's interesting because I thought about
that the last time I sat down with him
and I was pregnant with Ellis. I think
you said to me, don't ever become a woman,
Christine. Don't ever become
a woman. And I was like, wait,
what did you mean by that?
Because I've literally been thinking
about it for like two years.
When you're a comic, you're a
savage. Yeah. You're not a woman.
If you're on the road with me,
I'm not going to try to hit on you.
But the one in the room,
I'm going to Fart and you're going to
inhale it and I'm going to take my shoes
off and you're going to slow my feet
and it just becomes a part of your life.
Until one day you become a woman and go,
why am I sitting next to this fat fuck?
Talking about eating pussy and giggling
at his dumb jokes and smelled his feet
and his breath because you
were a comic tolerated it.
But one day the uterus
takes over and you're like,
why am I sitting next to this criminal?
Well, why? Why? What? What is what?
What is my PR? It was a good
point. Now I'm thinking, no,
you're a woman now who's
a mom and a comedian.
Now you got three ads and now you
have to balance that. That's right.
Because if you do get a VAD ain't go on
the road 40 weeks a year to pursue your
thing.
You've got to pay for this in 10 years.
Pens or commercial member panels or you
could me now you can pay me later. Yeah,
so now you were in a tough bind.
Now he has to know mommy does comedy and
it all works out and if you squeeze out
10 weeks,
which you'll be,
you're going to walk to the
airport those 10 weeks like,
do you know what I'm saying?
You know how now like all right honey,
I guess I'll see you on Sunday.
Those weeks when you're leaving.
Once he turns four it's like,
Tom, fuck you. Where's your ou?
But I'm running to the fucking airport.
Sunday.
I'm taking the late flight back.
You and Joe Diaz with that
6:00 AM flight. Yeah. Fuck you.
I'm taking the four o'clock flight.
Well sleeping late. We talked to
about this the other yesterday that the
thing that's great about the road now
when you, when you're a parent, the
really the, the the moment of it,
like the thing you savor is that you have
no responsibility while you're there.
I'm not on duty for eight hours.
You really feel like, yeah.
And what we're talking about is that the
best part is enjoying the hotel room.
It's like it's watching movies,
ordering room service, no row and like,
and like you know you,
you have all the freedom
to just do nothing.
Yeah. And Friday night cause
my favorite night on the road,
Thursday we've got to get up a radio.
Yeah.
Friday you're not
responsible for anything.
That's when I go back and I
cut my phone guy toenail. Yeah.
And I sniffed from my thrown behind the
beds and you rubbed by your feet with
the thing and you scratch deep.
He getting that sack. Yeah.
You try to figure out why you
have a lump next to eat balls.
That's the time I got a theory on that.
You go on like the Hotel Mirror.
Yeah as a spreadsheet and that sack
and you know that's Friday night.
I love that. I love it. I don't
have to get up Friday morning,
I get up Saturday morning, I get
the Hindu eggs, I get white bread,
I gets a quote. You know, cause there's
always said Indian people at the hotels.
So the Hindu eggs,
you wake up,
you go back upstairs and you sleep till
like one. That's great. You got up,
you go the Jeremy, a little lunch, little
college football you call Tom. How's,
how's the baby? Yeah. Great. Oh, you have
to see he walked through. That's great.
Great, good. Yeah, we'll
see you Sunday. I see.
Yeah. I mean, look, I have modified my
life so that I'm not out nearly as much.
It's like I'm out 48 hours and
then I'm fucking home dude. So,
you know what I mean?
Like I just don't do as much bullshit.
And you find that you don't need to do,
I don't fucking need to do
Wednesday through Sunday, Bro.
Like it's not even going
down. I don't even fucking do
Sundays. Uh, because of you
actually more than days.
That's what I'm saying.
I'm home bro. Like I'm fucking here
with my kid. All my husband, my dogs.
I think you inspired at all a whole
generation of people.
They should call it like the DA.
A lot of divorces. Yeah. Yeah.
I saw people disenfranchised
and really think about what,
get on a Sunday. I want you to really
think what you got on a Sunday.
What kind of piece of shit?
20 years ago.
We got people that have
the room on Sundays because
nobody would come to see us
on a Sunday.
We were opening for Joe.
Joe would leave on Saturday and that
would be the answer that stayed Sunday and
try to sell tickets by myself. And
then I asked myself why I was doing it,
even though I was single.
When I got off the coke,
I realized something that no matter, even
though it was a comic, I'm still a man.
And even though I was single and I had
a girlfriend and I had no responsibility
to it, there's nothing replaces
something they'd done it. I agree.
Replaces Sunday dinner. Nothing replaces
Christine pass the potatoes. Tom,
what's going on? Nothing.
Nothing. Your kid,
I don't give a fuck what
you do Sunday night.
I don't give a fuck of Sunday night.
You go to a strip club and stuck your
tongue up a strip his ass. All right.
But there's nothing like Sunday
dinner with your family. It's true.
Whether it's a girl that you date and
that's it. Cause it's not worth the paper.
That extra little paper
you're going to get,
you're going to lose that girl and 10
years from now, what are you going to do?
Sundays are so depressing
the spend on the road. It is.
It's absolutely as a feature act that
used to kill me to wait all day seven
o'clock show. Then you miss that red
eye. Yeah. You can't get 20 minutes.
You always met.
Like if you do Vegas,
Vegas and the show starts at nine
and you're like, I'm going at all.
There's no flights after eight 35 got
to leave Lake Phoenix, same thing.
You got like an early show in Phoenix.
Tried to leave early on a Sunday night.
You missed the flight by 20
fucking minutes as the worst.
Every fucking airline misses it
by 20 minutes. So you know what,
let's just stay home on Sunday. I love
getting home early Sunday, taking a nap.
By the time I wake up at two they are
alive and kicking. I got her all day.
You know,
we play no Sunday's the best
feeling,
especially coming off of work,
like coming off of shows to come
home Sunday, have a Sundae at home,
make Sunday dinner the
best we do Sunday trading.
Don't fuck up like agent. He's always
like, you know, like going on the road.
Do you hate it? I'm like, of course I
fucking hate it. I did it for a decade.
I've been done the road bro. Now he knows
like, but now my deals are better. Right?
Because I'm like, I'm fucking
doing it dude, until my deals are,
and that's also a lesson.
Before you were even moving tickets.
I remember like we were all,
you know,
like lucky to get work basically right?
Or your workforce and this is like six,
seven years ago and no,
none of us are moving tickets.
And then I'm talking to Dan,
I'm like, yeah, he goes,
are you doing Sunday shows? And I
was like, of course. He's like, yeah,
I don't do them. And I go
like, how do you not do them?
Because you just tell him no.
And I was operating from a place of fear.
Like how, what have you tell them
I won't do it. He's like, what are,
they'll give you the work.
It's like that you don't
do it. That's fine. But then he said it
no so much that. Then they'd be like,
all right, here's your Thursday
through Saturday. And I was like, yeah,
how can you get it?
That's all you have to do or
I'll do it the old fashioned way.
You want to fuck with me.
I'll books the sun that threatened
me with a Sunday and I'll take it.
But I guarantee I got do their
own movie that Monday. Oh right.
I have to leave on Sunday and
when then you fucked. Yeah.
Cause I'm not going to drop it on you
until Friday. Rob Schimmell style. Yeah.
You know, years ago,
nobody remembers this.
Rob Schimmell had Thursday through Sunday
at the Improv for like six months from
Rob Schimmell was hot 98 yeah.
But they created the show called like
how to marry a millionaire or something
and one guy was a comedian and he was
a comedian from the early nineties who
used to lie this pants on fire.
That was his opener opener.
Where do you go after that? And he would
go, is it hot in here? Is it me? Ain't no,
he was a funny comic and stuff,
but it revitalize his career.
So what at the Improv's
do they give loans?
They took everybody's Thursday away and
they gave it to him. So who would go,
okay. You know what time
Shim would cancel on Friday?
Like 6:00 PM two in the afternoon.
Oh,
you want to fuck up my Thursday?
Yeah, I'll fuck with you Friday.
So who canceled on him?
He did it three weeks in a row.
They never fucked with him again. He was
a bad motherfucker, man. He didn't know.
He was like that dog.
He canceled overnight with a fax.
Didn't wake up on eight o'clock. They
get the cotton for the Improv on Friday.
Soul dot.
Shimmel just canceled.
It looks like you're line lining
Joey. Oh yeah. That's the way it is.
And I've bumped into him at
an airport once and he goes,
sometimes you got to teach them a lesson
and who know who know who the fuck that
dealing with.
They want to sell you out for money.
They'll never saw y'all for money
again. He was a smart, savvy kind,
funny guy. Robert Schimmel and Hungarian.
And I'm Gary. Yeah. You know, we,
we live in the, uh, we've been, we
were robbed for 15 years. Right.
You ever go to check now
and you look at it, you go,
remember when we used to ask them for
$200 more and they told us they didn't
have it and now they're giving
us this check, you know,
whatever we got Rod. Yeah.
So now you know, they, they
really would do that. Oh yeah,
they did. Yeah, they did.
They wouldn't do a towel rooms. So yeah,
he did a lot of Kinky shit.
So now even an old dog gets a warm spot
on the sidewalk at one time or another.
Yeah. So now you got to
fucking pay the freight bitch.
Pay The freight.
That's true. And they all complain. The
club owners are like, well, I mean, how,
how come they, these big acts, they turn
into Dick's. It's like, what happened?
And I go, well, what happened is you guys
treat us like dog shit on the way up.
Yeah.
Now there's no fucking love left bitch
because you've been kicking us for 10
years.
Yeah.
So when you're at the top of the chain
is time for you to get yours because you
treat us like shit for so many.
Learn how to be assholes
from you. From you buy a car. Yeah. Yeah.
When you go buy a car now they give
you two options. They give you what?
I sold you a car. Whenever I sold you
a car, I just didn't sell your car.
I brought you back a purchase number
and I brought you back a lease number so
you could seat both options. Yeah.
We have the same option that yeah,
you can either take care of us at the
club will go to the theater across the
street. I won't make as much
money as that with Athena,
but I'll teach you a fucking lesson.
Yeah. Yeah. So you better keep you,
you saw a lot of cheeseburgers and
Joey's onstage Herbie's smoked reefer.
The Joey D's show. Yeah. So don't come to
me with this. No. Gee, this left, this d,
this lap. Yeah. And I want
it. Yeah. And if I don't get
it, I will sit at home. Yeah.
Then then, then, then that's it.
And that's just the way it is.
No, I know they, they
really do. Fuck you so hard.
And I don't want people at home to think
all these guys are whining. No, no.
I want you to think, listen, it
works also, when you're a mason,
if I could become a mason tomorrow
and I come to Christina, go,
cause she didn't want you to
teach me how to be a mason.
She's gonna teach me for 10 bucks an hour,
how to be a hod carrier.
Hod carrier is stocking the masons,
knowing how to put 16 bags of sand and
making cement and making sure they all
have some meth. They'll give
me a raise every six months to,
I love the $2 or whatever the fuck it is.
But then they're going to come a time when
they're going to go, I'm sick, jump in.
And now I'm laying brick
and I'm doing everything.
But they're still paying me the short
10 yeah, and they're charging 22 for me.
You're right. Do you follow me?
Yeah. Try and 22 on the bid.
So this happens in every occupation.
That's right. You know, not just comedy.
I don't want it.
This happens in plumbing where for two
years you're getting fucked in the ass.
Yeah. They go on, Christine,
how are you doing?
A will leaving you here today and
you're like, yeah, wait. Yeah.
You were in charge of Tom and Joey today.
Make sure the pipes are up
while the wiring is bold
and so for two years you get
fucked doing that too because he's out
golfing and you'll get, he's getting the,
that's true.
It's like any apprenticeship
mean apprentice even to
become like a doctor. Right.
You're broke for the first what
decade. Yeah. You're a student,
you're doing your rounds and then you
graduate and now you're a practicing
physician. I think in our
occupation, the graduation moment,
it's not as clear.
There's like a gray area where all of
a sudden you're moving tickets and now
it's like, and you have to fight
for your graduation is what it is.
You have to assert yourself. I
mean, what's that great story?
Who's the guy on the Sitcom? He's super
famous now. Gardendale Billy guard down.
I really got l. Yeah, he uh, he was
talking to somebody and this is like,
right when he became really successful.
He goes, yeah man, those $1,800 a weeks,
am I right? Like he was still
doing them right. Even as the,
he was doing television.
That's right.
So he didn't assert himself for the
raises and for the graduation, you know,
so, so, so crazy. 1800 and he's like a
big star. Yeah. But I mean, now he's,
he's making a way more of course.
Yeah. But I'm good for him.
He busted his ass for a while. Oh
yeah, absolutely. He's a funny guy.
He was always on like the side and he
was always put on a good show with his
shitty sidekick. Yeah. Who
would take down the show?
He had 20 chances he was unlucky.
Yeah. Guys don't remember.
He had the NBC show with a black kid that
was not funny. 20 million black people,
but a funny,
they gave him the other funny is black
guys a World War II is black guy.
Everybody,
everybody's funny is black.
I gave him the guy that couldn't be
funny if his life depended on it.
So true. There are so many funny
black people, Joey. That's very true.
Uh, so I'm fine. I'm fine.
I got my bed. Hmm. So, uh,
thanksgiving was, um, was a blast. We had,
we hosted at our house.
We had people over. Um,
we basically didn't do any work, but
it was totally worth it. It's great.
The outsourced all though to the
Hindus have them cook for us. And then,
um, I did the Wilbert or the Wilbur, the
Wiltern turn on, uh, on Saturday. Yeah,
it was amazing. Amazing. So Super Fun.
Thanks everybody here in La that
came out to the show. I'm also,
this is one thing that came in
a lot over the weekend was um,
are you going to 69 at 69 till we
get this thing up? My Dad turned 70,
uh,
earlier this year.
My favorite thing that we had a
big family reunion and my mom,
you know with Florida? Yeah.
That's when you went to Florida.
My mom is Peruvian and she doesn't, she's
not up on any of the lingo or anything.
So at this big dinner, I asked
my mom, I said, you know,
dad is turning 70 tomorrow.
Are you going to 69 him tonight? And she
was like, what? She didn't understand it.
So we would all laugh and make
and just joke about how, you know,
just just make fun of her
how naive she is. Right.
So we told people on our podcast
that you should do the same thing.
Ask your mom if she'll 69.
Your Dad when he turns 70 and they'd been
doing it and videotaping the reactions
to pass out. What a plan. I'm going
to play a few of them. If for example,
well, the, the milestone
[inaudible] 70th birthday, right?
When Tracy is about to turn 70,
um,
his last night of being 69 years old.
Um,
what'd you 69 him? Oh Shit. No.
Hell no, no, no.
Tracy York,
a little stone cold in the face there
on our about it. Mom. Mom.
Do you think when Dan,
he's about to turn 70 do you
think to celebrate as to like 69
why would you even ask
Zach? The first all was Austin from
Florida. Here's a Josh and Sarah.
I just had a question.
Are there, that's a prayer.
Thanksgiving for mom and dad.
Mom on the night before
pop's turns 70 years old.
Are you guys going to 69 yes,
absolutely.
We 69 just where you got here
but does always shit. I just hope
that buck place still in play. That
hello?
She's mortified. Yeah. Mom doesn't
even know what the Hell Riley.
Hey Mom, dad, buddy.
When he turned 70 are you going to let
mom 69 years like the day before he
turned 70 69 yeah. Mom,
are you going to 69
dead before he turned 70
she was funny. She got it. Yeah.
She got, here's the Maxima.
Your Mama when I'm a dancer
and 69 and dead 69th birthday.
Are you guys going to 69 yep.
Are you going to,
why would you do that filming?
we got a Spanish submission?
Yeah.
Oh yeah,
but it's a component that,
okay.
C d. All right. I'm going to see.
Yeah,
I'd say this is like another book deal.
The last name.
What did she say? What'd you say,
Joe Diaz? She said my pussy flip.
A pussy lips will be too long. They'll
be hanging down covering your eyes.
That's what you do with your bag after
50 you just take the pussy lips and put
them over your eyes like
you're flying on JetBlue.
You'll look that little buffalo.
Do you think
you two are going to be
together when he turned 70
wait,
what
are you guys are going to still
be together when he turned 70
yeah,
night before his 70th birthday.
You guys going to 69 last time?
Keep them high and tight.
Tight.
It's hilarious. That was
awesome. She goes, why does
it have to end at six tonight?
As I said,
that's all I have one last time that when
you see old people that still fuck all
you think about,
like when you see some old lady,
what if she was like the most prolific
Dick Soccer? Like, yeah. We were like,
you assume like, oh, she's an
old lady. She might've been like,
I used to blow the whole block. Yeah. Like
guys used to just drain. They're nuts.
Yeah. But you just assume because
she's old, but she doesn't have any,
you know, sexual history,
you know, but obviously,
or even my friends that are moms now do
I have this one friend in college that
was such a fucking whore,
like just everybody dumped clip
center and now she's super mom.
She's got two kids. She's
always on Facebook, like
posting the activities again,
like, dude, you were such a fucking whore.
Like when I think of all
the Jews inside of her.
Yeah. It's gotta be a lot. Ah, it's not
even the same person now. No, I know.
But that's the thing is that she's
gonna, you know, few years later, right.
10 years from now,
20 years from now.
And one day she'll be just like a nice
old lady and someone will be like, oh,
watch your mouth in front of her and
don't say right. And then you'll be,
you'll walk up and be like, Oh, I've
known this horse and she's 18. Every guy,
every guy on the fucking, uh, on the
block got a chance to ride it out. Yeah.
Yeah. Like when you think about your
grandma, like she sucked so many days.
She might have, you know, she
sucked your granddad's dig
for sure. Costume. Yeah. Well, it's
crazy how my friend's mom, my friend,
his dad died about two years ago and I
talked to him a lot and I will always
take growing up and I always ask
them, how's your mom? He goes,
my mom's a different woman.
He goes,
cause my dad was 15 years old and she was,
and she married him when she was 20.
So now he,
she wanted to an old folks home and he
knows his mom. They go out on dates,
you know,
the mamma like it's a complete goes out.
There's days I don't talk to him. Yeah.
She's go to Atlantic City, she goes,
you went to see Hamilton, you know, they,
they have these lives and 70 where
they gotta be doing something. Sure.
We've Viagara and if you've got
a good heart, you still fucking,
I just can't imagine what
a pushy looks like at 70.
And when it would smell
like it smells dusty or
I saw a, when I've seen an old one, I
saw what at 84 I saw hunter. You what?
It looked like. It was pretty, it was
pretty gnarly. How did you see an 84 year?
I went and watched a surgery.
Uh,
I was doing this research
paper on surgery,
like just the history of surgery and
they let me go to the hospital and then
they're like, you're going to witness
all of these, um, uh, you know,
OBG surgeries today. And
I was like, oh, okay.
The very first one,
they were like,
we're going to remove a cyst from this
old lady's purse. And I'm like, okay.
And they're like, make sure you don't talk
about it because she's awake, you know?
And I was like, oh, okay.
And then they post you up right
underneath her spread legs.
They undrape it and they go in there
and there's like a softball size cyst
inside of her and they pop it and
it's shooting pass out and it,
and everybody's like,
Holy Shit.
And actually it was good thing that
they're reminded us not to say anything
because your natural instinct was
just to go like, what the fuck? No,
but we got everyone kind of can be awesome
thug compose these bug up.
But yeah,
gnarly man was, yeah, it was beat up.
Well, I've seen a hundred year old
lady when I was in high school,
I did Christian service hours and we had
to change this lady for her hundredth
birthday and I took off her dress and
I saw her lavia hanging out through her
underwear.
Like one of them was hanging out of
her panties and they get real hanging.
The lip scale like,
yeah,
well what a Dick and balls do when they
got a hundred they've got to really hang.
No, get 54 it's no fucking
beauty queen. Well,
that was 30 I had a nice looking
dick who was veiny. It was tight.
It's veiny the toe next.
All fucked up now.
Now the ball's got a real one of
your balls. Like, oh my balls.
Are they in the water? Are
they in toilet water? Ah,
well I've always had naturally
fucking big balls. Yeah. Yeah.
Now that just,
but the Dick looks like Frankenstein's
Floyd from not wearing underwear.
Yeah,
I quit my helmet on the Zipper,
so I've got a thousand of those cars.
I'm like,
I wouldn't have a show my dick to a
young girl, like if a 20 year old.
So I really want to suck your Dick. It
would be traumatizing for sure. Yeah,
it's bad enough. He goes,
nevermind the 54 year old deck.
Like what do you believe he was
sucked Harvey Weinstein's. Damn man.
They really going to burn and
Listerine take that dictates
your heroes.
God,
I can't wait till he comes out with all
the tapes and the women that did suck
his Dick Pussy. Ain't that stupid. He's
creepy. You think he's got tapes? Oh yeah.
He's got like a young Angelina Jolie
drinking blood sucking Deca the same, Huh?
Slit her arm and stuck of his thing.
He's this crazy.
He really is Gollum. No, that guy's
a fucking nightmare. He really is.
But then again,
you know
it's in a movie kind of worth
it. So Dude, do you want,
do you remember a few weeks ago I played
you a one of our listeners calling into
like this nerdy fucking news show,
right?
The Dad boners and I go on like a Kiva
high and tight and the two fucking nerds
were like keep it high and tight.
So like it's like a catch phrase from
our show and they're calling these two
guys and these guys keep reading it on
their news show like that or fucking
make-believe. Good Morning America
style show. It's like a local, yeah,
these Justin.
Hey guys,
this is my favorite part of the day
watching from work and really keep them
jeans high and tight. Funny. Every time.
Justin, why he gets you every time?
Yeah.
Okay. So wait, this is live at
13 ABC. Wham. Where's, well,
I think it's in Rochester.
And you'd have a guy that left.
You could tell he suck the Dick.
Well how do ya do you have to get the
shirts tailored to be that tight around
your biceps doing that on purpose for
sure. That's what a Ryan Gosling does too.
I noticed. But this guy, his
shirts normal. Yeah. When
he gets him tailored tight.
Right? Well the guy on the left wants
you to know what's up. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Uh,
Justin's checking in from work.
Hope you guys are having a
great an eventful day. Keep
them jeans high and tight.
So there you go.
The second,
second time. Right. Then
let's go back from it.
Uh, Michelle likes your genes.
Yeah. People were liking the jeans.
You're wearing jeans and they're a
little short. Uh, Justin. Hey guys,
I love your shirts.
Hope you guys have a great day.
Keep them jeans high and tight.
Justin,
we are wearing jeans today and actually
his are a little high. That's my concern.
Be High your jeans? No, not on your
waist. Oh good. There are a little short
tilt down. Carmen, what's going on
there? A little. Yeah. He's got,
the dad sneaks onto that flood fucking
pants on. Yeah. When he sits down,
it looks like his Dick is
strangled to in these pants.
He's got the European
tighties on hungry buds. Yeah.
Yeah.
Hi Justin. Checking in. Pink. Pink
Day today. You guys have a good day.
If you know what the guy says.
Nice stuff.
So we're going to read you a little line
to compliment us.
We're going to save your life.
It will say your lines.
So then, okay. Doubling Fag.
They dance. They catch on.
Let's, oh they're catching
on. They catch on him. This
next one. And then they, they,
they take jabs at us.
Oh,
but they do it in like the
hackiest fucking lame way.
So like they don't say who we are, but
they do here. I'll just play it for you.
Okay.
Hey, Justin healer's back. He's our
guy. I say you should talk to Justin.
It's a white shirt. You
heard about Justin's efforts?
Yes. Both ties are on fleek.
Hope you're having a great day.
Keep them mommy's high and tight.
We know about your mommy. Can we do? We
know all about your boundaries, Justin,
not one. Mommy. You got two
mommies. You got two claws.
I entertaining people on a podcast
and Kelly, please sit in a basement.
And I emphasize, I found a little
humor from these comedians. See,
we can be unfunny. Yeah, but we
are not, we know how many gurus,
we don't claim to be funny. We don't
profess to be a float. All we just are.
We don't just, that's right.
Speak for yourself. But anyway,
the mommies do and uh, we appreciate them.
Ridiculous. We don't seem to be funny.
We don't profess to be a failure at all.
We just are.
We don't profess to have any
talent. That's right. Speak
for yourself. But anyway,
the mommies do. And um, we appreciate that
virtual asset. Yup. They're showing, hey,
it's fun.
Hey, it's fun. These guys are fun. Yeah.
Huh. Okay. Well, the bottom, you're like,
this is their, their style of humor is
like, make a branch and get over it.
That's their job. Their
base. This is our basement.
I think that this studio is
probably nicer than theirs. Yeah.
Like are you fucking shitty basement
that a guy that scored major films yet
built in our basement. All
right guys. Well you know
what, you are very funny. Um,
at Wham, they coordinate.
Do you think they talk,
they call each other in the morning
and they coordinate the outfits?
Probably shirt colors and the ties and
stuff. Yeah, I think they probably do. Um,
I know that the day of a, like you
said, they're just naturally funny guys.
And I feel like the nice thing would be
if they heard about how funny they are.
So what I would just say, hey guys,
this is my favorite part of the day.
You know what, why don't you hit
these guys up and, and tell them.
So this is Scott here.
Scott Asco.
Yeah. I mean I've at 13, wham, wham,
wham, wham. He's uh, he's, Oh, here we go.
So he's at Scott Hasko. Okay. H E t t.
H. E. T. S. K. O. Tell
him, telling me like, dude,
we were watching your,
your show with Matt.
You are so fucking funny.
You're the funniest guy we have.
I thought I knew comedy. Yeah.
Until I watched live at 13.
Wham. And now I know what
funny is. Now I laugh.
You and Matt are two true comedy pioneers.
You don't even have to claim to be funny.
We're watching your show and you guys
are just that naturally. Let them know.
Let's look the mommy's on them.
Let them know. Remind them. I mean,
tell them you guys are,
your studio looks great and
you're really fucking funny guys.
So make sure you tell them that
they, they're hilarious. Yeah.
Yeah. They're funny guys.
I almost feel kind of,
I almost feel bad for like, they're just,
they're such boners, you know? Yeah,
they are. They're pretty bad. Um, no,
but they're doing their Rochester
thing and you guys keep doing it, man.
We're proud of you. You're very funny
guy. Ganges. Speaking of boners um,
we see sometimes people get excited about
the shit that I don't think you should
get excited about and we kind of
call them, we call them dad boners.
Like this guy gets excited about,
you know,
the Trans Canada highway. Okay.
Just to give you some rough.
Oh, oh, oh,
ah,
no.
Says the Canada high
way baby,
like what do you think of that guy?
He's never fucked outside
this stationary position.
If he ever 60 90 to have a heart attack,
doesn't it drive you crazy?
But one man's chicken is
another man's fucking, yeah,
so you have to look at it from that.
You know,
it's like when you take
your kid to go see a,
your Bob look at their face. Their
face is fucking, this is God.
You know, he's some dude making eight
bucks an hour long for college degree.
But you know it's weird. It
is weird. What something,
it's like when people
come up to you and go,
I want to show you pictures from
my vacation. I don't give a fuck.
You know what the best and you
did this morning. Not often me.
A tour of your house. I don't want to tell
your fucking bedroom. All right. Yeah.
For Yourself. What's the
living room? Let's see the TV.
You invited me over for breakfast.
Where's those eggs you were talking about.
Know what I'm saying?
People want to show you shit that
you don't really want to fucking say.
That's totally true. I think
drives me crazy and that, yeah,
I can't see without my glasses.
So when you show me a picture of your
trip to the Grand Canyon and I can't see
it, but people have to lie to
people show you pictures. Oh yeah,
they drive me fucking crazy. You don't
remember when you didn't have kids?
Somebody sent me a Christmas
card with a picture of the rug.
We kid when the report on the year,
I breed them and now I put the picture
that get up on the wall because I hope
they do the same to me. You know?
It's so weird how things change.
We were talking about change last night,
how,
who we were 15 years ago
and who we are today.
That's why I don't mind getting called
out on the other mistake I made. Right.
But you can't call me out on something
I did 15 years ago because we've all
changed in 15 fucking
years. Yeah. That, you know,
you want to call me out because when
we were shooting a student film,
Christine in 1998 I smack your ass.
Give me a break.
You're going to ruin my life
because I smacked your ass.
Even though you had hot pants on.
And we're talking about how
hot your friends say you asses.
How many times have you gone through his
set and people acting fucking totally,
totally fucking wrong. Even the women
are acting totally wrong, you know,
so that's what's pissing me off.
But what's going on lately?
We all fucking change 15 years ago.
Who the fuck knows what?
I have to take my dick out in front of
and whacked off. No, but with Christine,
wait to see if I've ejaculate it.
No.
Christine would have left who sits around
and waits for come to come all over
your stomach.
And for me to sit that
Christina wasn't the way it is,
Christina would've kicked me in the
stomach and ran out of that. Yeah,
I know this for a fact. Christina,
hold on. Let's discuss comedy.
I really like your podcast with Joe.
I want to show you a little
bug on the my Dick. No.
Yeah. Well you know how many guys I've
seen jerk off in public a lot? No.
Since I was 12 where I've
seen guys jerk off in church.
I've seen guys jerk off
under freeway underpasses,
losses in the South Bay, Redondo in front
of our house, in front of our house.
I parked his car, homeless guys in front
of banks. I'm telling, I've seen but,
but how many of them do I watch
and finished to completion?
Fucking 0.0 you know what I'm saying?
You can turn around and get the fuck
out of there. Yeah. Or call the cops.
I called the cops on that guy. Yeah.
Uh, yeah. It's, it's everywhere. It's,
I'm dropped off from my car.
What is the twice well yeah,
you mentioned that one time. The one
that can write code. We coke. Yeah.
I had nowhere to go at night.
You got to come down. Yeah.
But I think one time on an ex girlfriend
call me was telling me about harass,
hold all this shit and I got so hot in
the four oh five I'd take that big one
out and it'd be in the Hov Lane.
If cal is a third path,
if the cop pulls me over.
What is your second passenger
right here in between my legs.
Here he is alive and kicking
you nasty as hell Joe.
Oh God.
Oh you want me to come up here?
Get over Michael Brennan.
Do you think those guys 69 though
to one of them wants to 69 for sure.
I don't know.
Well let's do with that pink shirt.
He'll suck my ass hole like
a fucking chicken wing.
Oh Man. Oh God. How do you spell it?
Correct.
Double back down. This guy here,
it gets real excited about it.
Today we are celebrating
something very special.
My daughter's BFF is losing it too in
the most glorious and one of a kind ways.
It has never been done before. I've
done my internet research. Okay,
so this is the plan. Yes, of
course. This is non alcoholic.
Carbonated cider in a champagne bottle.
We are going to remove it to why?
Celebrating.
Okay.
What the fuck is he doing? He's going
to pop the cork to take the tooth out.
No, I don't like this at all.
It's all right. It's nothing
to, it's just going right. That's it.
Oh my gosh guys.
This nerve gets so excited.
Did you feel anything?
Who else feels that energy
at the park? One day you're
going to come in for a second.
I want to pop a bottle with my Dick.
Suck your Dick.
The four daughters embarrassed. She's
like, my dad's such a Dick sucker.
I mean you could just tell total
dick sucker. Yeah, he's damn it man.
He's done some,
a lot of questionable shit.
Yeah.
All the kids was like the fuck are you
talking about to say as a woman that does
make my pussy dry. Yeah. Like
this is the kind of guy that
finds those two news guys. Funny.
That's the demographics is does
he live in Rochester and Wham?
No. What? Justin,
do you want Jeff to recuse buffalo treaty?
This stuff about it. You know?
What do you like about it?
It's a with different, I've always been
a big fan of Buffalo, so about Buffalo.
I liked the people I talked to guy on
the road this year from buffalo all year.
Yeah. Cool guy. The radio.
Yeah. Yeah. Josh Potter. Yeah.
You know, great guy. Great Guy.
Josh. Paula. That's right. Cause he's
worked with you too. I love Judge Pollack.
He's great. He's a, he looks like, so
he was like a young pee wee Herman.
You could jerk off in the movie theater,
but you wouldn't give a fuck.
Even peewee.
He jerked off in the movie theater.
It didn't bother anybody.
If it happened now,
I wonder if his career would be as over.
You know what I mean?
I feel like that's nothing
compared to today's standards.
We got a six fingertips.
Hey Hitler's,
I'm just a black guy that got out of
jail and like to fuck. I had to stop.
I had to stop my come hug to write
this email about the question of the
advantages and disadvantages of being
born with six fingers as a glass then
moves to be made with six fingers.
On one hand,
I could answer this puzzling question.
We in the sixth fair community do
not acknowledge a middle finger.
Also from experience. It
is not an advantage in the
fingering men, women, Zim,
Windsor's, but I believe it does add to
the experience when you rub, rub, rub.
Thanks.
Water champ and Christina machines within,
please fuck my triple d slot wife, your
boyfriend, the Trans Canada highway. Sam,
the rainmaker. Well, he got a lot of
them in there. That's quite the answer.
I can't wait. Sorry. I keep thinking
about those too. Dorky news casters is,
when are the mommies rain?
The fury on those guys?
I have no idea what's
about to happen to them.
I know they're going to have some fun.
I guarantee we have way more listeners
than they do or you have no idea what
they just fucking did. I know they're
going to fuck with the wrong people,
the wrong people.
Then they're going to have to,
they're going to end up shutting
down their Twitter, bio,
terrain fury, uh, the wet butthole
research. Okay. And Mommy's,
I'm a regular shit to shower.
Participant. Great. Do you do that job?
Oh, this is shit in the
show, in the shower,
every once in a while pieces fall that
you're in there. You over committed,
but you take a shit
mean you're showering
and then pieces of shit.
Tom Did you take, sometimes you jump in
the shower, you wake up late, you're late,
you're not thinking and you're like,
fuck,
I'm supposed to take a ship
before the shower. Or you're like,
what am I going to do it dry off and
go out and start from scratch? No, no,
no.
You're not around that shit.
And then you take a stick and you
push it down the hall. Yes, I did.
I thought it would be three or four times.
My wife caught me and my wife called
me one time and throwing a piece.
She caught you throwing a terrible
one time. She caught me with my hand.
Throw it into the toilet.
Yes,
she did throw up and then she got upset.
She to live. We're done with that.
I've never just pop a squat.
Right.
Pop a squat but thing and in
hotels on the road. Yeah. If they,
oh I think a good shit in the shower.
I don't give a fuck.
And it has like those four things and
the beauty of it is the shower has,
the fourth thing is so it's like when
you were a kid and you had Plato and you
push the shot, the
shampoo. Baba. Yeah Bro.
I don't fuck around in Vegas at that big
shout when the presidential suite and
they got that big hole or my
God on a regular day though.
But I haven't done it about 10
years. I'm going to lie. Yeah,
it's been about if you
take a shit on the toilet,
do you wipe and then get in the shower
or do you just take it all right.
Here's the day.
Remember a couple of weeks ago when the
plane went down because the guy farted
and it was really bad couple
of weeks ago for flight,
had it go down because somebody
farted and it was really bad. Okay.
I had the whole explanation to that.
Okay. I'm a morning shit. Yeah.
But I can't wake up and shit. I
have to wake up, drink coffee,
do a piece of nicotine gum that
gets the interior going. Yeah.
Then smoked dope. Then you smoke. Right.
So I opened the back
door while I'm smoking,
the shit starts coming out of me, so
I'm smoking while I'm shitting. Okay.
So that's that first really, really
good shit in the fucking day. Yeah.
And then you go and then I take a shower.
My ass is tip top Magoo and
I have no other problems. If,
if I shit, it's maybe like
at six and before I go out,
I'll take a shower to go to the
comedy store. Okay. So that's,
that's that one thing. I'm a
morning shit. Who's a morning?
What happens if you don't like that
dude that got on the plane that day?
The plane had to be taken down a 10 I've
been there because you got up at five
you ate breakfast,
Uber came before you can take a shit.
You walk into the bathroom at lax,
it's a tornado of shit. Odors.
Have you ever walked through the
middle of the men's bathroom?
It's 10 guys shooting at once
and you're like,
I'm not going to take a shit on me.
Then you have the oatmeal and you're going
to have that fucking four hour flight
and you were asked after two hours.
Listen,
only in animal cause shit on the
flight has done it a few times.
I've done it for emergency shifts
and not like a casual show. If it's,
I will hold it till it's
coming out of my ear balls,
eyeballs before I share on a plane.
That's disgusting. It's gross.
It is not really disgusting,
but they do the best they can because
the structure goes up. Your farts smell,
you know they do the best they can.
They happen on that flight. He held it.
He held did. He held it and then
you get those pre farts. Yeah.
It's like when you're driving home,
you could drive home.
You don't need to take a shit once.
Your asshole processes the exit.
Yes. Okay. One Laurel Canyon,
but you hit violent as soon as you're
asking your eyes connect with Laurel
Canyon. Yeah, it's like two miles.
Now Watch your asshole hits the ramp.
There's a magnet on the off ramp.
That bull shit out of your ass, Nigga.
She goes, that first light. When you're
going off that over that you pray to God,
you go,
Lord of there's a fucking God.
Please don't let that be a red light
there and there's always a red light
because that mag needle pulls that,
that last bump.
Now you're at that light,
your foot's tapping.
Think of that fart that comes out first,
that the appreciate Fart is horrific.
You can't even tolerate it. You got
the windows open, you got the air on,
it's thick, it's warm.
It's really a, once you go,
when you feel it slipping out of your ass,
and that's tremendous.
When you sit and that first 14 inches drop
and you hear the water hit
your ass her and be like, Ooh.
And then he'll like little pieces like
you have to go to a hot dog factory.
You ever go to Sab Brighton hot
dog factory? When I was an old CIO,
he works study program that made us go
there. That's what my ass hoes life.
When you go to the Sab bread factory,
it's a hole in the floor like the six by
six foot circle and there's a bunch of
Puerto Ricans with rules.
All right,
and this dream Puerto Rican
with bags of 80 pound salt.
I'm not making this up,
I didn't want to insult you.
You know.
So there's a duct duct,
Christine,
it's all pieces of the cow
and the pig that are not used.
The hearts, the eye balls. Did
you just see him coming down,
Blah Blah Blah and it smells horrible
and you see like three Puerto Ricans put
the salt on down and 10 Puerto Rican.
They sweep it into a hole and that's
where it gets processed and it becomes on.
That's how the hot dog is.
Probably that's how your asshole is.
That's how your asshole,
well I dunno,
I lost whatever thought I had but didn't
you recently have a huge shit you were
saying last week when they came
from New York it was four days.
Eat for some reason,
correct me,
we take shits on the road but
they're not really good shit.
I have to look at them and go, it's
like a nine inch. It's not a lot.
This shit I take when you get home.
When I walk in that door you put that
luggage down and I run for the back
bathroom.
The Shit I took was like
a cane when I flushed it.
If you could hear the cane breaking like
they have like a bone in the middle.
It was going to finally broke and it
flooded and I had the pleasure and I will,
the next morning I come
back and I see my wife,
she went and got a snake at Kmart cause
I'm always fucking that bathroom up.
I fucked that bathroom so good.
You can't take a shower back there really?
Because sometimes the shower over floods
from this shit. I taken that batch.
Listen, when I picked that house, I
pick a house because of the bathroom.
Everybody looks at living rooms and
family rooms. If the bathroom a proper,
you're not going to live right.
I want my bathroom and he just spread
my legs out. I want a window. Yeah.
I want to CB radio. I want
to see be, I want a phone.
I want my back. I don't know playboy. They
have my wife. No playboy and open house.
Yeah. Books I want. I want,
I like to day in there now,
but they,
the tushy cushion,
you put the hot water when the hot
water hit you and when you open up that
thing, I mean it really, you'll,
it'll leave. You wouldn't know.
You could eat off your ass.
It's like it's beautiful and you take some
water and then I, I took a loofa. Yeah.
You go to bed, bath and beyond and you've
got a big Lou for, you got a good one,
but you cut it into little
asshole loofahs. Oh, that's
a good idea. I have an APP,
looser loafer every night.
90 days I change it.
You dispose of it.
One use and gone like every two or
three weeks after the fucking know.
But I don't understand.
Listen to me,
you take the thing and you let the big
day, the tushy hit your ass, right? Yeah.
And it takes all the chunks and
fingernails and all the, all the big shit.
Then you take Roland
pay, uh, toilet paper.
You wet it first and then you massage
it and this, it's clean. Yeah.
Now to exfoliate the ass. Yeah,
because that's what nobody does.
Everybody's washes and wipes,
but nobody is fully hcs hall,
the Loofa and you take the other
one and you just, you know,
exfoliate that little last home. Yeah. And
later on, later on when you're driving,
you go for a little drive and when
nobody's watching you stick your finger in
your ass and you scratch it
and it smells tremendous.
It smells like that little
Lou for like that little clam.
I bet you joy as a really nice ass.
Do you know why?
Because I want somebody to look at,
nobody's ever looked at,
but if they really illiquid,
I'm not saying
no stop.
No decent woman.
No woman that's going to bury your
children is going to fucking eat your ass.
Your wife is eating your
ass on the rag. No, no,
but she showed that she really should
date and she had to eat my ass one time.
If not,
I can bury it.
You got to suck the ball suck and just
pick up that canal and licked that
asshole like this. Thank you. And
you have to be drunk to do it.
Like you know you're not going to get a
single woman to lick your ass on unless
he's a savage. Yeah, it was a drunk woman.
I've gotten the girl coked up your ass
holes the first and that gets lit and
they could smell like Newark that don't
give a fuck. Go read that ass. You know?
Listen if I'm fucked up and you got good
pussy and I bend you over the 69 you'd
eat your ass from bond.
It's got a Wang to it.
You think I'm going to tap you and go
Christine, you got wagging your ass.
I'm a soldier. I gotta either with
that way cause he's a real commitment.
Pled rocky bunny
because we had a debate on this
show that this guy was like,
the only way I'm going to get a
girl's butt is if it's totally clean.
It doesn't smell. He doesn't love it. No,
no. I don't want to eat. You're
pushing me to come out of the shower.
I want you to go to yoga.
Yeah.
I want you to come back from yoga with
those little pubic hairs. All scores.
Oh my God.
People,
let's say new jog four miles and
come back. When is that pussy smell?
It's tremendous sweaty.
It smells like a gyro.
Eg staple of the gyro right above
whatever the fuck it is.
I gotta tell you this,
this guy now you know why
don't join Lincoln then
fuck, I agree with you when Lincoln
fucking stupid. What is legal?
Sending some songs. Admissions. You
want to hear him so crazy isn't it? And,
and machines were then, so this guy
has been making, has been writing
machines. Was Dan that got
a gun and got again? Yeah,
I've got a gun terminating her gun. Yeah.
Machines. But then machines was thin.
Gs 16 two six two two six to 100%
she's 16 shoes with thin or shootings.
I love your podcast. You find this shit.
So this guy, wait, what do you think?
What do you think of a song? Like
what do you feel? Think that's a song.
It was 16 1600% hold on.
I though he's telling him about
his testosterone levels. 16 to 16
thanks guy.
But you can
see where it's the kernel of
like something good. Right?
Like could be a good fall.
Yeah. Yeah. He's onto something.
Just don't tell nobody I'm am I told
the kid once he picked me a score.
Yeah, I think it, he's like,
what do you think? I go, listen,
that's a high level script.
But don't tell nobody that.
He's looking at me like why go?
Cause everybody will jump on it.
Tell us solar but not a show. Keep
it. We're going to work on it.
It was that bad. Yeah. It's weird when
you talk somebody down from a bad idea.
But this, like you said, there's
definitely something here. Yeah.
So this came in for a
machines with intake.
This is great.
This is good.
Very good.
This is a fantastic
John Powers from New Hampshire.
Wow.
Joey likes it. Not Bad man.
This is it. The same song Joe.
But see, we have towns, had listeners, the
other guy didn't have the studio. Yeah,
that's right. No, he didn't have access
to the studio that day. That's right.
Jason from Sacramento did an acoustic
version of machines within, yeah.
I haven't heard it.
But
we have some very talented listeners
musically inclined people who will take
the, uh, the Corto.
Got It.
Okay.
In this Terminator Matrix
Free Three on many times,
I'm going to say this,
machines with machines
with loud at two 16,
which means sound to make
beautiful and practice,
some of which are fine.
Go long
term.
Very, very nice. I actually think that's,
that's beautiful. Yeah. So last week,
the same, um, artists
submitted another song.
This guy, my introduction, my song I
just made on Facebook. Crazy, isn't it?
Well, who would I go? I'll
drop that birthday party.
Crazy. Isn't it crazy, isn't it?
That first drop that
first got the not crazy,
isn't it? Got that knife crazy.
Isn't it crazy, isn't it?
Yes. Yes. Yes.
This was the same guy that was walking
down the street. The same guy. He
must be a fan. Found the Telemundo.
He likes that fucking wrestling mats.
Tyler more gray. Loves wrestling
first. How crazy. Isn't it?
Innocence. Innocence. Crazy.
Innocent. Is it? It's incidents.
Innocence answer, isn't it? So he did.
That's great.
Then
people started sending in their version
of my song I just made on Facebook.
It's called crazy.
The old Firebird diary ends all gallery.
I think he's right it right.
See,
this is a produced by,
it's a dark too.
I just made on Facebook. It's called
crazy, isn't it? Well who? I'd go out
crazy. No, it's good.
Z Z,
Z is you get the vibe that first
and then this is innocent. My, by Ricardo,
I mean on Facebook, it's called crazy,
isn't it?
Well, who are our goals? Please, please,
please, please. Cool.
In this place and this place.
Who, who, who in this place?
Tennis played tennis
care.
It's demonic. Right? And there's a
last one here. This is by Adrian trap.
Really good [inaudible] on Facebook.
It's called crazy.
Or I go out and talk to her
birthday party. Yes, yes,
yes, yes, yes. To face. Hey,
Batman first burst.
This one's my favorite.
I think I'm a fan of trap
one.
Yeah.
Some of these are good.
I think your theory has always in right.
He just needs to be paired
up with the right producer.
And that's what these initial passes are.
This is the first round of producers
that have stepped up. Yup. Next week,
the week after. We're going to hear it.
Different variations on the song. Um,
just so people know. So
for this whole week, uh,
you can get 15% off on my store.
Go to a merchant method.com/tom Segura.
Use the code,
Cyber 15 C Y B e r 15.
You get 15% off everything in the store,
just glass and bikes,
um, machines within, uh,
the, the Santa wears jeans,
hat, all that stuff. A
Co people ask me about,
um, machines within guy, um, uh,
about his shirt and he is getting
a, um, money for it. So He's,
we've reached out. Don't
worry about it. He'll be good.
He'll definitely have a check
coming to him. Um, but anyways,
so go to the store.
The only thing not going to be on sales.
Here's a charity sweater a,
it says San Jose,
Santa Claus wears jeans and um,
that all that money goes to a
children's Hospital of Los Angeles.
So that's not on sale, but everything else
is vinyl. All that shit. Vinyls crazy,
crazy, crazy vinyl. So, um,
I think that's about
it. Gene. We have, uh,
one other thing here and
then it's time to go.
Um, first of all, thanks a lot of joy
for coming by. Thank you for having me.
I don't want to see the house and the
baby. Yeah, it was beautiful little boy.
You guys did good. Thanks.
He's a good kid. Um,
somebody wrote to us. Uh, I went
to the post office. As you know,
post offices are fairly quiet for
the most part. As soon as I walk in,
I hear an older lady blaring church
music through her phone. Hmm.
While waiting to be called
with her number was called.
She didn't turn off the music. You just
set her phone on the counter. Well,
getting helped by the employee.
All of us there were stunned
and no one said anything.
I should have said something or let it
pass. I really, I didn't really mind,
but it was weird and uncomfortable. Thanks
gs. Nicholas, I think you're insane.
Yeah.
If you're walking around playing music
and then put your phone down and play
music through it.
I even think people are crazy walking
around playing music when they're walking
around and how loud for everybody,
like we all have to hear your fucking
musical preferences. I think so.
We should definitely say something.
I did some great. I've been in righting
wrongs. Don't say anything to her.
She's out of her fucking mind. Oh, well
you don't know what she's going to do to,
you know, let her do it and just get
on with your life. Those people have,
are out of, she's done on
another fucking reality. Dude.
My respect goes up 10 fold for people
that say something in those situations.
I've been in a waiting room where
somebody was on a phone and there's one of
those office waiting rooms where it says,
don't use phone and somebody else
in the waiting room and said, hey,
get off of your phone. And I was like,
ah. And the other person goes, excuse me.
And she goes, don't you see the sign? It
says you can't be on the phone in here.
And so the lady was like, Hey,
um, I think I got it. I loved it.
I love all that shit. I get it sold.
Say nothing unless it really affects me,
but yeah, yeah, yeah. When somebody steps
up like that, I think it's the best man.
It really gets me excited.
Um, so go see Joey Diaz.
He'll be at the Sacramento punchline.
You only have two shows left.
You can get into December 7th, which
is Thursday. Yeah, Thursday and Friday.
Like the arrows show.
The late show probably is one of them.
So that'd be the eight
Sacramento punchline. A
checkout Diaz. Uh, Christina P,
you can see a mother and fury on
Netflix if you have not yet seen it.
It's streaming on Netflix.
She'll be in New York next few days.
Yeah, I'm doing the stern
wrapup show on Thursday.
So if you guys listened to that,
I'm
so fucking excited. I'm such a huge
fan and I can't wait to nerd out.
Um, and then she has her dates
available at Christina p online.
That should come into, uh,
uh, Short Lake titties.
Charlene say that Port Portland Horrigan
and Pasadena and then Calusa Colusa
Casino, which I think, uh, I think
Diaz and I did that together. Oh, stop.
My favorite thing about,
well,
he had an edible with him before a
flight and I lost my mind and he was just
talking to all kinds of crazy shit.
I thought I was going to pass
out from laughing. Then we, we,
we did a southwest flight together and
he goes, go sit by the window. And I go,
okay, why? He goes also by the aisle.
There's no way someone's going to want
to sit between. Fuck. There you go.
All right.
We said that worked for all those flights.
I remember that.
I finally like started to come down
off of this edible and I was like,
man, that was horrible. That was horrible.
And I come down and I go, I just,
I'm amazed at his tolerance and I go,
I just can't believe how
much you can tolerate.
Like I was really like having
anxiety, I guess you don't. He's like,
what are you talking about? I almost had
three panels and I go and I go, dude,
you don't mind that. He's
like, what are you going to do?
And then we walk outside and I'm like,
thank God I'm coming down. He goes,
you want to smoke a joint?
I don't want to do anything.
I don't want to do anything for a year.
Yeah, he was just right back at it.
How do you deal with the panic attacks?
Cause that's why I can't take live,
breathe, just breathe. Do you
talk to yourself like don't
feel it and you're like,
I chill the worst panic attack as if I
eat an edible and I have to do something
run upstairs or that's
when I get panic attacks.
Like something active has to be done.
Oh yeah. Okay. But besides that,
I'm pretty good. Yeah, that's yours. Okay.
Do you do an activity? Do you ever
like watch TV to calm yourself down?
Sometimes when you're too high
I just go to sleep really well.
I'm too high. I just
passed the fuck out. Yeah,
it gets to that level where you
just want a little too deep.
Just take a little nap. I remember we
got to Calusa, I still remember this,
we've got the CALUSA and they're like,
do you guys want to go to the buffet?
We were like, sure. But I was still had
that like after high where you know,
you know you're not as hungry as you
think you are because the weed is making
you feel like you have much.
So I go to the buffet line and I come
back with a salad because I'm trying to
fight the feeling of just overindulging
so I know I'll eat myself sick is what I
feel like.
So I,
I show up at the table and then joy
shows up and he's got like four plates of
like all different treats. And he's
like, who the fuck are you? And I go,
when he's like eating a salad. What are
you fucking Puerto Rican or something?
Some shit like that. And I'm like, what? I
go, I don't want to eat crazy. He's like,
go get yourself something
to eat. Come back. He would
real fucking food. Then I go,
okay, so go back. Yeah,
we fucked up. Fuck.
The weight watcher points with two
stones were stolen out of our minds.
You're the best dude. Thanks
for coming. Great podcast.
I love the videos.
I love your quirkiness and I wish you guys
nothing but success. You, you're great.
Couple of so thanks brother. We
love you. Thanks guys for listening.
We'll see you next week.
Santa Claus is black.
How come you don't want any clauses?
Latino. Santa Claus is Asian.
Santa Claus is black Santa Clauses Latino.
Santa Claus is Asian.
Santa Claus is black. Santa Claus
is Latino. Santa Claus is Asian.
Craig,
ah, ah, ah.
To flush things.
Downer energy channel and elk route.
It's helpful if we make
sound.
Santa Claus is a black Santa Clauses
Latino. Santa Claus is Asian.
It's important to that groundwork done
and complete our sacred releasing ritual
that we go close.
The
how,
how
her secrets releasing virtual
real moose they could
for the main markets is black.
Santa Claus was Latino.
Asian Santa Claus is black or Latino.
Santa Claus is Asian.
Santa Claus is a black,
Santa Claus is Latino.